and the gentleman from Texas mr. Paul is
recognized for 60 minutes as the
designee of the majority leader
I Thank You mr. Speaker I ask unanimous
consent to revise and extend my remarks
without objection so ordered mr. speaker
this may be the last time I speak on the
House floor at the end of the year I'll
leave Congress after 23 years in office
over a 36 year period my goals in 1976
were the same as they are today promote
peace and prosperity by a strict
adherence to the principles of
individual liberty it was my opinion
that the course of the u.s. embarked on
in the latter part of the 20th century
would bring us a major financial crisis
and engulfed us in a foreign policy that
would overextend us and undermine our
national security to achieve these goals
I saw it the government would have had
to shrink in size and scope reduce
spending change the monetary system and
reject the unsustainable costs of
policing the world and expanding the
American Empire the problems seem to be
overwhelming and impossible to solve yet
from my viewpoint just following the
constraints placed on the federal
government by the Constitution would
have been a good place to start just how
much did I accomplish in many ways
according to conventional wisdom my
off-and-on career in Congress from 1976
to 2012 accomplished very little no name
regulation legislation no name federal
buildings or highways thank goodness
in spite of my efforts the government
has grown exponentially taxes remain
excessive and the prolific increase of
incomprehensible regulations continues
Wars are constants and pursued without
congressional declaration deficits rise
to the sky poverty is rampant and
dependency on the federal government is
now worse than any time in our history
all discs with minimal concerns for the
deficits and unfunded liabilities that
common sense tells us cannot go on much
longer
a grand but never mentioned bipartisan
agreement allows for the well-kept
secret that keeps the spending going one
side doesn't give up one penny on
military spending the other side doesn't
give up one penny on welfare spending
while both sides support the bailouts
and the subsidies for the banking the
corporate elite and the spending
continues as the economy weakens and the
downward spiral continues as the
government continues fiddling around our
liberties and our wealth burn in the
flames of a foreign policy that makes
makes us less safe the major stumbling
block to real change in Washington is
the total resistance to admitting that
the country is broke this has made
compromising just to agree to increase
spending inevitable since neither side
has any intention like cutting spending
the country in the Congress will remain
divisive since there's no loot left to
divvy up without this recognition the
spenders in Washington will continue to
march toward a fiscal cliff much bigger
than the one anticipated this coming
January I've thought a lot about why
those of us who believe in Liberty as a
solution have done so poorly in
convincing others of its benefits
if Liberty is what we claim it is the
principle that protects all personal
social and economic decisions necessary
for maximum prosperity and the best
chance for peace it should be an easy
sell yet history has shown that the
masses have been quite receptive to the
promises of authoritarians which are
rarely if ever fulfilled
should we have authoritarianism or
Liberty if authoritarianism leads to
poverty and war and less freedom for all
individuals and is controlled by rich
special interests the people should be
begging for Liberty there certainly was
a strong enough sentiment for more
freedom at the time of our founding that
motivated those who were willing to
fight in the revolution against the
powerful British government during my
time in Congress the appetite for
Liberty
has been quite week the understanding of
his significance negligible yet the good
news is that compared to 1976 when I
first came to Congress the desire for
more freedom and less government in 2012
is much greater and growing especially
in grassroots America tens of thousands
of teenagers and college aged students
are with great enthusiasm welcoming the
message of Liberty I have a few thoughts
as to why the people of a country like
ours once the freest and most prosperous
allowed the conditions to deteriorate to
the degree that they have freedom
private property and enforceable
voluntary contracts generate wealth in
our early history we were very much
aware of this but the earth in the early
part of the 20th century our politicians
promoted the notion that the tax and
monetary system had to change if we were
to involve ourselves in excessive
domestic and military spending that is
why Congress gave us the Federal Reserve
and the income tax the majority of
Americans and many government officials
agreed that sacrificing some Liberty was
necessary to carry out what some claim
to be progressive ideas pure democracy
became acceptable they failed to
recognize that what they were doing was
exactly opposite of what the colonists
were seeking when they broke away from
the British some complain that my
arguments make no sense since great
wealth and a standard of living improve
for many Americans over the last hundred
years even with these new policies but
the damage to the market economy and the
currency has been sidious and steady it
took a long time to consume our well
destroy the currency and undermine
productivity and get our financial
obligations to a point of no return
confidence sometimes lasts longer than
deserved
most of our wealth today depends on debt
the wealth that we enjoyed and seemed to
be endless allowed concern for the
principle of a free society to be
neglected as long as most people believe
the material abundance would last
forever worrying about protecting a
competitive productive economy and
individual liberty seemed unnecessary
the age of redistribution this neglect
assured in an age of redistribution of
wealth by government counting to any and
all special interests except for those
who just wanted to be left alone that is
why today money and politics far
surpasses money currently going into
research and development and productive
entrepreneurial efforts the material
benefits became more important than the
understanding and promoting the
principles of Liberty in a free market
it is good that material balance is a
result of Liberty but materialism is all
that we care if but if materialism is
all that we care about problems are
guaranteed the crisis arrived because
the illusion that wealth and prosperity
would last forever has ended since it
was based on debt and a pretense that
death can be papered over by an
out-of-control Fiat monetary system it
was doomed to fail we have ended up with
a system that doesn't produce enough
even to finance the debt and no
fundamental understanding of why a free
society is crucial to reversing these
trends if this is not recognized the
recovery will linger for a long time
bigger government more spending more
debt more poverty for the middle class
and a more intense scramble by the elite
special interests will continue we need
in intellectual awakening without an
intellectual awakening the turning point
will be driven by economic law a dollar
crisis will bring the current
out-of-control system to its knees if
it's not accepted that big government
fiat money ignoring liberty central
economic planning welfarism and warfare
ISM caused our
prices we can expect a continuous and
dangerous march toward corporatism and
even fascism with even more loss of our
liberties prosperity for a large middle
class though will become an abstract
dream this continuous move is no
different than what we have seen in how
our financial crisis of 2008 was handled
Congress first erected with bipartisan
support bailouts for the wealthy then it
was the Federal Reserve with his endless
quantitative easing if at first it
doesn't succeed try again qe1 qe2 qe3
and with no results we tried QE
indefinitely
that is until it too fails there is a
cost to all of this and let me assure
you delaying the payment is no longer an
option the rules of the market will
extract the power its pound of flesh and
it won't be pretty the current crisis
elicits a lot of pessimism and the
pessimism adds to less confidence in the
future the to feed on themselves making
our situation worse
if the underlying cause of the crisis is
not understood we cannot solve our
problems the issue of warfare and
welfare deficits inflation ISM and
corporatism bailouts and
authoritarianism cannot be ignored by
only expanding these policies we cannot
expect good results everyone claims
support for freedom but too often it's
for one's own freedoms and not for
others too many believe that there must
be limits on freedom they argue that
freedom must be directed and managed to
achieve fairness and equality thus
making acceptable to curtail through
force certain liberties some decide what
and whose freedoms to be limited to be
limited these are politicians whose goal
in life is power their success depends
on gaining support from special
interests
we don't need more isms the great news
is the answer is not to be found in more
isms the answers are to be found in more
Liberty which costs so much less under
these circumstances spending goes down
wealth production goes up and the
quality of life improves just this
recognition especially if we move in
this direction increases optimism which
in itself is beneficial the
follow-through with sound policies are
required which must be understood and
supported by the people but there is
good evidence that the generation coming
of age at the present time is supportive
of moving in the direction of more
liberty and self-reliance the more this
change in direction and the solutions
become known the quicker
will be our return to optimism our job
for those of us who believe that a
different system than the one that we
have had had for the last hundred years
has driven us to this unsustainable
crisis crisis is to be more convincing
that there is a wonderful uncomplicated
and moral system that provides the
answers we had a taste of it in our
early history we need not give up on the
notion of advancing this cause it worked
but we allowed our leaders to
concentrate on the material abundance
that freedom generates while ignoring
freedom itself now we have neither but
the door is open out of necessity for an
answer the answer available is based on
the Constitution individual liberty in
prohibiting the use of government force
to provide privileges and benefits to
all special interests after over 100
years we face a society quite different
from the one that was intended by the
founders in many ways their efforts to
protect future generations with the
constitution from this danger has failed
skeptics at the time of the Constitution
was written in Knight H 1787 warned us
of today's possible outcome the
insidious nature of the erosion of our
liberties
and the reassurance our great abundance
gave us allowed the process to evolve
into a dangerous period in which we now
live dependency on government largesse
today we face a dependency on government
largesse for almost every need our
liberties are restricted and government
operates outside the rule of law
protecting and rewarding those who buy
or coerce government into satisfying
their demands here are a few examples
undeclared wars are commonplace welfare
for the rich and poor is considered an
entitlement the economy is
over-regulated overtaxed and grossly
distorted by a deeply flawed monetary
system debt is growing exponentially the
Patriot Act and FISA legislation passed
without much debate have resulted in a
steady erosion of our 4th Amendment
rights
tragically our government engages in
pre-emptive war otherwise known as
aggression with no complaints from the
American people the drone warfare we are
pursuing worldwide is destined to end
badly for us as the hatred builds for
innocents lives lost in the
international laws flaunted once we are
financially weakened and militarily
challenged there will be a lot of
resentment thrown our way it's now the
law of the land that the military can
arrest American citizens hold them
indefinitely without charges or trial
rampant hostility toward free trade is
supported by a large number in
Washington supporters of sanctions
currency manipulation and WTO trade
retaliation call the true free traders
isolationists sanctions are used to
punish countries that don't follow our
orders bailouts and guarantees of all
kind of misbehavior are routine central
economic planning through monetary
policy regulations and legislative
mandates has been acceptable policy have
a few questions excessive government has
created such a mess it prompts
many questions why are sick people who
are who used medical marijuana
put in prison why does the federal
government restrict the drinking of raw
milk
why can't American manufacturers
manufacturers rope and other products
from him why are Americans not allowed
to use gold and silver as legal tender
as mandated by the Constitution why is
Germany concerned enough to consider
repatriating their gold held by the Fed
for her in New York is it that the trust
in the US and dollar supremacy beginning
to wane why do our political leaders
believe it's necessary to thoroughly
audit why do our political leaders
believe it's unnecessary to thoroughly
audit our own gold
why can't Americans decide which type of
light bulbs they can buy why is it the
TSA permitted to abuse the rights of any
American traveling by air Why should
there be mandatory sentences even up to
life for crimes without victims as our
drug laws require why have we allowed
the federal government to regulate
commodes in our homes why is it
political suicide for anyone to
criticize AIPAC why haven't we given up
on the drug war since it's an obvious
failure and violates the people's rights
has nobody noticed that the authorities
can't even keep drugs out of the prisons
how can making our entire society a
prison solve the problem why do we
sacrifice so much getting this son
getting necessarily involved in border
disputes and civil strife around the
world and ignore the root cause of the
most dangerous deadly border in the
world the one between Mexico and the
United States why does Congress
willingly give up its prerogatives to
the executive branch
why does changing the party and power
never change policy could it be that the
views that both parties are essentially
the same why did the big banks the large
corporations and foreign banks and
foreign central banks get bailed out in
2008
in the middle-class lost their jobs and
their homes why do so many in the
government and the federal officials
believe that creating money out of thin
air creates wealth why do so many accept
the deeply flawed principle that
government bureaucrats and politicians
can protect us from ourselves without
totally destroying the principle of
Liberty why can't people understand that
war always destroys wealth and liberty
why is there no so little concern for
the executive order that gives the
president authority to establish a kill
list including American citizens of
those targeted for assassination
why is patriotism thought to be blind
loyalty to the government and the
politicians who run it rather than
loyalty to the principles of Liberty and
support for the people real patriotism
is a willingness to challenge the
government when it's wrong why is it
claim that if people won't or can't take
care of their own needs that people in
government are able to do it for them
why did we ever give the government a
safe haven for initiating violence
I keep against the people why do so many
members defend free markets but not
civil liberties why do so many members
defend civil liberties but not free
markets aren't they the same why don't
more defend both economic Liberty and
personal liberty why are there not more
individuals who seek to intellectually
influence others to bring about positive
changes those who seek power changes
than those who seek power to force
others to obey their commands why does
the use of religion to support a social
gospel and pre-emptive Wars both of
which require authoritarians to use
violence or the threat of violence go
unchallenged aggression and forced
redistribution of wealth has nothing to
do with the teachings of the world's
great religions why do we allow the
government and the Federal Reserve to
disseminate false information dealing
with both economic and foreign policy
why it is democracy held in such high
esteem when it's the enemy when it's the
enemy of the minority and makes all
rights relative to the dictates of the
majority why should anyone be surprised
that Congress has no credibility since
there's such a disconnect between what
politicians say and what they do is
there any explanation for all the
deception the unhappiness the fear of
the future the loss of confidence in our
leaders the distrust and the anger and
frustration yes there is and there's a
way to reverse these attitudes the
negative perceptions are logical and a
consequence of bad policies bringing
about our problems
identification of the problems and
recognizing the cause allow the proper
changes to come easily we should have
more trust in ourselves less than the
government too many people have fard for
too far too long place too much
confidence and trust in government and
don't have enough in themselves
fortunately many are now becoming aware
of the seriousness of the gross mistakes
of the past several decades the blame is
shared by both political parties many
Americans now are demanding to hear the
plain truth of thing things and want the
demagoguing to stop without this first
step solutions are impossible seeking
the truth and finding the answers in
liberty and self-reliance promotes the
optimism necessary for restoring
prosperity the task is not that
difficult if politics doesn't get in the
way we have allowed ourselves to get
into such a mess for various reasons
politicians deceive themselves as to how
wealth is produced excessive confidence
is placed in the judgment of politicians
and bureaucrats this replaces the
confidence in a free society too many in
high places of authority became
convinced that only they armed with
arbitrary government power can bring
about fairness while facilitating wealth
production this always proves to be a
utopian dream and destroys wealth and
liberty it impoverishes the people
Ward's the special interests who end up
controlling both parties it's no
surprise that much of what goes on in
Washington is driven by aggressive
partisanship and power seeking with
philosophic differences being minor
economic ignorance is commonplace
Keynesianism continues to thrive
although today it is facing healthy
enthusiastic rebuttals believers in
military Keynesianism and domestic
Keynesianism continue to desperately
promote their failed policy as the
economy languishes in a deep slumber
supporters of all government edicts use
humanitarian arguments to justify them
humanitarian arguments are always used
to justify government mandates related
to the economy monetary policy foreign
policy and personal liberty this is on
purpose to make it more difficult to
challenge but initiating violence for
humanitarian reason reasons is still
violence good intentions are no excuse
and are just as harmful as when the
people use with and force with bad
intentions the results are always
negative p.m. immoral use of force is
the source of man's political problems
sadly many religious groups secular
organizations and psychopathic
authoritarians endorse government
initiated force to change the world even
when the desired goals are
well-intentioned or especially when the
where they're well-intentioned the
results are dismal the good results saw
never materialized
the new problems created require even
more government force as a solution the
net result is institutionalizing
government initiated violence and
morally justifying it on humanitarian
grounds this is the same fundamental
reason our government uses force for
invading other countries at will central
economic planning at home and the
regulation of personal liberty and
habits of our citizens
it is rather strange unless one has a
criminal mind and no respect for other
people in their property knowing
claims it's permissible to go into one's
neighbor's house and tell them how to
behave what they can eat smoke and drink
or how to spend their money yet rarely
is it asked why it is why is it morally
acceptable than a stranger with a badge
and a gun can do the same thing in the
name of law and order any resistance is
met with brute force fines taxes arrest
and even imprisonment this is done more
frequently every day without a search
warrant no government monopoly over
initiating violence is what we need
restraining aggressive behavior is one
thing but legalizing a government
monopoly for initiating aggression can
only lead to exhausting Liberty
associated with chaos anger and a
breakdown of civil society preventing
such Authority and expecting a saintly
behavior from the bureaucrats and the
politician politicians is a pipe dream
we now have a standing army of armed
bureaucrats in the TSA CIA FBI Fish and
Wildlife FEMA RS Corps of Engineers etc
numbing over a hundred thousand citizens
are guilty until proven innocent in the
unconstitutional administrative courts
government in a free society should have
no authority to meddle in the social
activities or the economic transactions
of individuals nor should government
meddle in the affairs of other nations
all things people peaceful even when
controversial should be permitted we
must reject the notion of prior
restraint in economic activity just as
we do in the area free speech and
religious liberty but even in these
areas government is starting to use a
backdoor approach a political
correctness to regulate speech a very
dangerous trend since 9/11 monitoring
speech on the Internet is now a problem
since warrants are no longer required
the proliferation of federal crimes the
Constitution established for federal
crimes today the experts can't even
agree on how many federal crimes are now
on the books they number into the
thousands no one person can comprehend
the enormity of the legal system
especially the tax code due to the
ill-advised drug wars and the endless
federal expansion of the Criminal Code
we have over six million people under
correctional suspension more than the
Soviets ever had in more than any other
nation today including China I don't
understand the complacency of the
Congress and the willingness to continue
their obsession with passing more
federal laws mandatory sentencing laws
associated with drug laws have
compounded our prison problems the
Federal Register is now seventy five
thousand pages long and a tax code
seventy two thousand pages and expands
every year when when will the people
start shouting enough is enough and
demand Congress to cease and desist what
we should be doing is cheap achieving
Liberty Liberty can only be achieved
when government is denied the aggressive
use of force if one seeks Liberty a
precise type of government is needed to
achieve it more than lip service is
required there are two choices available
one a government designed to protect
Liberty is a natural right as its sole
objective the people are expected to
care for themselves and reject the use
of any force for interfering with
another person's Liberty government is
given a strictly limited thorry to
enforce contracts property owner ships
settles disputes and defend against
foreign aggression number two a
government that pretends to protect
Liberty but is granted power to
arbitrarily use force over the people
and foreign nations though the grants of
power many times is meant to be small
and limited it inevitably metastasizes
into an omnipotent political cancer this
is the problem for which the world has
suffered throughout the ages though
meant to be limited it never lasts is a
100 percent sacrifice of the principle
that would be tyrants find irresistible
it is used vigorously though
incrementally and insidiously granting
power
to government officials always proves
the average the adage that power power
corrupts once government once government
gets a limited concession for the use of
force to mold people's habits and plan
the economy it causes a steady erosion
and a steady move toward tyrannical
government only a revolutionary spirit
can reverse the process and deny the
government this arbitrary use of
aggression there is no in-between
sacrificing a little Lewbert live a
little liberty for Imaginary safety
always ends badly
today's mess is a result of Americans
accepting option number 2 even though
the founders attempted to give us option
number 1 the results are not good as our
liberties have been in roted our wealth
has been consumed the wealth we see
today is based on debt and a foolish
willingness on the part of foreigners to
take our dollars for goods and services
then they loan them back to us to
perpetuate our debt system it's amazing
that it has worked for this long but the
impasse in Washington in solving our
problems indicate that many are starting
to understand the seriousness of this
worldwide debt crisis and the dangers we
face the longer this process continues
the harsher the outcome will be the
financial crisis is actually a moral
crisis many argue knowledge saying that
a financial crisis looms but few
understand its in reality a moral crisis
it's the moral crisis that has allowed
our liberties to be undermined and
permits the exponential growth of
illegal government power without a clear
understanding of the nature of the
crisis it will be difficult to prevent a
steady march toward tyranny and the
poverty that will accompany that
ultimately the people have to decide
which form of government they want
option number one or option number two
there is no other choice claiming there
is a choice of a little tyranny is like
describing pregnancy as a touch of
pregnancy it is a myth to believe that a
mixture of
free markets and government central
economic planning is a worthy compromise
what we see today as a result of that
type of thinking and the results speak
for themselves a culture of violence
Americans now suffer from a culture of
violence it is easy to reject the
initiation of violence against one's
neighbor but it's ironic that the people
arbitrarily and freely anoint government
officials with monopoly power to
initiate violence against the American
people
practically at will because it's the
government that initiates force most
people accept it as being legitimate
those who exert the force have no sense
of guilt it is believed by many by too
many the government's are morally
justified in initiating violence
supposedly to do good they incorrectly
believe that this Authority has come
from the consent of the people the
minority were victims of government
violence never consented to suffer the
abuse of government mandates even when
dictated by the majority victims of TSA
excesses never consented to this abuse
this attitude has given us a policy of
initiating war to do good as well it has
claimed that war to prevent war for
noble purposes is justified this is
similar to what we were once told that
quote destroying of his village to save
a village close quote was justified it
was said by a US Secretary of State that
the loss of 500,000 Iraqis mostly
children in the 1990s as a result of
American bonds and sanctions was worth
it to achieve the good we brought to the
people of Iraq and look at the mess at
Iraq is in today government used a force
to mold social and economic behavior at
home and abroad has justified
individuals using force on their own
terms
the fact that violence by government is
seen as morally justified is the reason
why violence will increase when the big
financial crisis hits and becomes a
political crisis as well first we
recognize that individuals shouldn't
initiate violence then we give the
authority to the government
eventually the immoral use of government
violence when things go badly will be
used to justify an individual's right to
do the same thing neither the government
nor individuals have the moral right to
initiate violence against another yet we
are moving toward the day when both will
claim this Authority if this cycle is
not reversed society will break down
when deeds are pressing and conditions
deteriorate and rights become relative
to the demands and the whims of the
majority it's then that not as it its
then not a great leap for individuals to
take it upon themselves to use violence
to get what they claim is theirs as the
economy deteriorates and the wealth of
discrepancy increase as they already are
occurring violence increases as those in
need take it in their own hands to get
what they believe is theirs they will
not wait for a government rescue program
when government officials wield power
over others to bail out the special
interests even with disastrous results
to the average citizens they feel no
guilt for the harm they do those who
take us into undeclared wars with many
casualties resolving never lose sleep
over the deaths and the destruction
their bad decisions cause they are
convinced that what they do is morally
justified in the fact that many suffered
just can't be helped when the street
criminals do the same thing they do have
no remorse believing that they are only
taking what is rightfully theirs all
moral standards become relative whether
it's bailouts privileges government
subsidies or benefits for some from
inflating a currency it's all part of a
process justified by a philosophy of
forced redistribution of wealth violence
or a threat of such is the instrument
required and unfortunately is a little
concern of most members of Congress some
argue it's only a matter of fairness
that those in need are cared for there
are two problems with this first the
principle is used to provide a greater
amount of benefits to the rich than to
the poor second no one seems to be
concerned about whether or not it's fair
to those who end up paying for all the
benefits the costs are usually placed on
the backs of the middle class and are
hidden from the public eye
too many people believe government
handouts are free like printing money
out of thin air and there's no cost that
deception is coming to an end the bills
are coming due and that's what the
economic slowdown is all about sadly we
have become accustomed to living with
the illegitimate use of force by
government it is the tool for telling
the people how to live what to eat and
drink what to read and how to spend
their money to develop a truly free
society the issue of initiating force
must be understood and rejected granting
to government even a small amount of
force is a dangerous concession limiting
government excesses versus a virtuous
moral people our Constitution which was
intended to limit government power and
abuse has failed the founders warned
that a free society depends on a
virtuous and moral people the current
crisis reflects that their concerns were
justified many politicians and pundits
are aware of the problems we face but
spend all their time in trying to reform
government the sad part is that the
suggested reforms almost always leads to
less freedom and the importance of a
virtuous and moral people is either
ignored or not understood the new
reforms serve only to further undermine
Liberty the compounding effect has given
us the steady erosion of Liberty and a
massive expansion of debt the real
question is if it is Liberty we seek
should most of the emphasis be placed on
government reform or trying to
understand what a virtuous and moral
people means and how to promote it the
Constitution has not prevented the
people from demanding handouts for both
rich and poor in their efforts to reform
the government while ignoring the
principles of a free society all
branches of our government today are
controlled by individuals who use their
power to undermine Liberty and enhance
the welfare warfare state and frequently
their own
wealth and power if the people are
unhappy with the government performance
it must be recognized that government is
merely a reflection of an immoral
society that rejected a moral government
of constitutional limits it's on power
and love of freedom if this is the
problem all the tinkering with thousands
of pages of new laws and regulations
will do nothing to solve the problem it
is self evidence that our freedoms have
been severely limited in the apparent
prosperity we still have is nothing more
than leftover wealth from a previous
time this fictitious wealth based on
debt and benefits from a false trust in
our currency and credit will play havoc
with our society when the bills come due
this means that the full consequence of
our lost liberties is yet to be felt but
that illusion is now ending reversing a
downward spiral depends on accepting a
new approach expect the rapidly
expanding homeschooling movement to play
a significant role in the revolutionary
reforms needed to rebuild a free society
with constitutional protections we
cannot expect a federal government
controlled school system provide the
intellectual ammunition to combat the
dangerous growth of government that
threatens our liberties the internet
will provide the alternative to the
government media complex that controls
the news and most political propaganda
this is why it's essential that the
internet remains free of government
regulation many of our religious
institutions and secular organizations
support greater dependency on the state
by supporting war welfare and
corporatism and ignore the need for a
virtuous people I never believed that
the world or our country could be made
more free by politicians if the people
had no desire for freedom under the
current circumstances the most we can
hope to achieve in the political process
is to use it as a podium to reach the
people to alert them of the nature of
the crisis in the importance of their
need to assume responsibility for
themselves if it is Liberty that they
truly see
without this a constitutionally
protected free society is impossible if
this is true our individual goal in life
ought to be for us to seek virtue and
excellence and recognize that
self-esteem and happiness only comes
from using one's natural ability in the
most productive manner possible
according to one's own talents own
talents productivity and creativity are
the true source of personal satisfaction
freedom and not dependency provides the
environment needed to achieve these
goals government cannot do this for us
it only gets in the way when the
government gets involved the goal
becomes a bailout or a subsidy and these
cannot provide a sense of personal
achievement achieving legislative power
and political influence should not be
our goal
most of the change if it is to come will
come will not come from the politicians
but rather from individuals family
friends intellectual leaders and our
religious institutions the solution can
only come from rejecting the use of
coercion compulsion government commands
an aggressive force to mold social and
economic behavior without accepting
these restraints inevitably the
consensus will be to allow the
government to mandate economic equality
and obedience to the politicians who
gain power and promote an environment
that smothers the freedoms of everyone
it is then that the responsible
individuals who seek excellence and
self-esteem by being self-reliant and
productive become the victims in
conclusion what are the greatest dangers
that the American people face today that
impede the goal of a free society there
are five the continuous attack on our
civil liberties which threaten the rule
of law and our ability to resist the
onrush of tyranny number two violent
anti Americanism that has engulfed the
world because the phenomenon of blowback
is not understood or denied our foreign
policy is destined to keep us involved
in many wars that we have no business
being in national bankruptcy and a
greater threat to our national security
will result
number three the ease in which we go to
war without a declaration by Congress
but accepting international authority
from the UN or NATO even from for
pre-emptive Wars otherwise known as
aggression a financial political crisis
as a constant number for a financial
political crisis as a consequence of
excessive debt unfunded liability
spending bailouts and gross discrepancy
and wealth distribution going from the
middle class to the rich the danger of
central economic planning by the federal
reserve must be understood world
government taking over local and US
sovereignty by getting involved in the
issues of war welfare trade
banking a world currency taxes property
ownership private ownership of guns must
be addressed happily there's an answer
for these very dangerous trends what a
wonderful world it would be if everyone
accepted the simple moral premise of
rejecting all acts of aggression the
retort to such a suggestion as always
it's too simplistic too idealistic
impractical naive utopian dangerous and
unrealistic to strive for such an ideal
the answer to that is after thousands of
years the acceptance of government force
to rule over the people at the sacrifice
of liberty was considered moral and the
only available option for achieving
peace and prosperity what could be more
utopian than that meant considering the
results especially looking at the state
sponsored killing by nearly every
government during the 20th century
estimated to be in the hundreds of
millions of people it's time to
reconsider this grant of authority to
the state no good has ever come from
granting monopoly power to the state to
use aggression against the people to
arbitrarily mold human behavior such
power when left unchecked becomes the
seed of an ugly tyranny this met this
method of governance has been adequately
tested and the results are in the
reality dictates we try Liberty the
idealism of non-aggression and rejecting
the offensive use of force should be
tried the idealism of government
sanctioned violence has been abused
throughout history and is the primary
source of poverty and war the theory of
a society being based on individual
freedom has been around for a long time
it's time to take a bold step and
actually permit it by advancing this
cause rather than taking a step
backwards as some would like us do today
today the principles habeas corpus
established when King John signed the
Magna Carta in 1215 is under attack in
our own government there's every reason
to believe that a renewed effort with
the use of the Internet that we can
instead advance the cause of Liberty by
spreading an uncensored message that
will serve to rein in government
authority and challenge the obsession
with war and welfare what I'm talking
about is a system of government guided
by the moral principles of peace and
tolerance the founders were convinced
that a free society could not exist
without immoral people just writing
rules won't work if the people choose to
ignore them today the rule of law
written in the Constitution has little
meaning for most Americans especially
those who work in Washington DC Benjamin
Franklin claimed quote only a virtuous
people are capable of freedom John Adams
concerned quote our Constitution was
made for a moral and religious people it
is wholly inadequate for the government
of any other
immoral people must reject all violence
in an effort to mould people's beliefs
our habits a society that booze or
ridicules the Golden Rule is not a moral
Society all great religions endorse the
Golden Rule the same moral standards
that individuals are required to follow
should apply to all government officials
they cannot be exempt the ultimate
solution is not in the hands of the
government the solution falls on each
and every individuals with guidance from
family friends and community the number
one responsibility for each of us is to
change ourselves with hope that others
will follow this is of greater
importance than the working on changing
the government that is secondary to
promoting a virtuous Society if we can
achieve this then the government will
change it doesn't mean that political
action or holding office has no value at
times it does not see in the right
direction but what
is true is that when seeking office is
done for personal aggrandizement money
or power it becomes useless if not
harmful when political action is taken
for the right reasons it's easy to
understand why compromise should be
avoided it's also become clear why
progress is best achieved by working
with coalitions which bring people
together without anyone sacrificing his
principles political action to be truly
beneficial must be directed toward
changing the hearts and minds of the
people recognizing that it's virtue and
morality of the people that allow
Liberty to flourish the Constitution or
more laws per se have no value if the
people's attitudes aren't changed to
achieve Liberty and peace to powerful
human emotions have to be overcome
number one is envy which leads to hate
and class warfare number two is
intolerance which leads to bigoted and
judgmental policies these emotions must
be replaced with a much better
understanding of love compassion
tolerance and free market economics
freedom when understood brings people
together when tried freedom is popular
the problem we have faced over the years
has been that economic interventionist
are swayed by envy where a social
interventionist are swayed by
intolerance or have habits and
lifestyles the misunderstanding that
tolerance is an endorsement of certain
activity motivates many to legislate
moral standards which shouldn't only be
set by individuals making their own
choices both sides use force to deal
with these misplaced emotions both are
authoritarians neither endorses
volunteerism both views ought to be
rejected I have come to one firm
conviction after these many years of
trying to figure out the plain truth of
things the best chance for achieving
peace and prosperity for the maximum
number of people worldwide is to pursue
pursue the cause of Liberty if you find
this to be a worthwhile message spread
it throughout the land and I yield back
the balance of my time
it's back